good afternoon and welcome to at Yale
live I'm Eric gersan today we talk about
a life in science with a man who's lived
it to the fullest James E Rothman
professor and chair of the Yale School
of medicine's Department of Cell Biology
and a winner of the 2013 Nobel Prize in
physiology or medicine as always we'll
take some of your questions please
submit them via Twitter to Yale or by
email to social media yale.edu Jim
Rothman thanks for being with us
pleasure Eric so on the day that you won
uh the no Nobel Prize you taught all
your scheduled classes tell tell us a
little bit about why that was
important well you know um teaching is
an important obligation and uh I think I
was trying to send a message to the
students and also my
colleagues that uh you know we uh should
keep our focus on the most substantial
things teaching is a very substantial
thing research is a substantial thing
and uh you know was wonderful to have
received an award like this but it's in
recognition we hope of substantial
things so let's remember the substantial
things tell us a little bit about uh the
the Nobel ceremony and the experience
and all the hoopla surrounding that oh
no that's a really big question because
it's uh it's uh it's I I it's an
experience I would recommend to
anybody uh you know but to be serious
it's uh it it's like stepping into
another world and uh it's quite quite
quite an unreal experiment experience
the
Swedish uh one of the things you learn
is that um the Nobel Prize for the
Swedish people has a significance above
and beyond by far uh what it does
internationally for them it's almost
like a national celebration it comes at
the time of the year when uh when when
the when the there is the least light in
a in a country that is in Scandinavia
and it's dark in the winter and uh so
it's made into a festival of light uh
and it's become a very very important
part of the Swedish
brand uh and their brand Equity if you
want to think about it in economic terms
uh and political terms so it's the level
of Celebration is really quite
extraordinary was there an opportunity
to mingle with uh laurates in other
disciplines uh or were you mainly with
your fellow scientists and uh well both
actually so there are quite a number of
all the official events involved all of
the Nobel laurates except for the Nobel
Peace Prize which is awarded uh in Oslo
MH all of the other ones are awarded in
in Stockholm and so you spend actually
quite a bit of time getting to know uh
some interesting new folks and their
families and uh uh you know and actually
some of the children became friendly and
I'm told that my three-year-old
granddaughter was quite friendly with
Eugene F's uh three-year-old
granddaughter and so you know there
relationship's yet to come well that's
uh an amusing uh anecdote that I think
we both understand but Eugene F won the
shared the Nobel Prize in uh the
economic Sciences with Bob Schiller who
is on the faculty here at Yale had you
met Bob before or well actually the
first time I met Bob was right in this
studio I mean Yale is a is a here yeah I
mean Yale is a big place and uh we're in
different faculties and I've only been
here for 5 years yeah but I have to say
that uh that Bob and I became quite
friendly uh and uh continued to be
friendly and uh as do our families and
so uh out of this will come uh a very
good you know uh and fun uh relationship
we actually continue to send each other
little notes about how's it going uh and
uh sharing uh some a few hints about how
to survive uh as a Nobel laurate Bob was
telling us that he had to and he was
joking but he declared email bankruptcy
after he won uh the Nobel Prize because
he was so inundated with email
congratulatory people asking him to do
things so on and so forth uh and he felt
that he should respond in some way to
each of them but he couldn't possibly I
don't know if you had a similar sort of
experience well I I would never trust an
economist who claims he
bankrupt uh of course you know you get a
lot of email uh I I I tried my very best
to answer all the email that that uh
that came in the early days but yeah
there are are a lot of requests some of
them are are kind of amusing but and I
won won't reiterate them here but for
the most part uh what happens is that uh
life gets back more towards uh normal
yeah which is a good thing let's talk
about science a little bit on the uh on
the day that you won the prize um you
gave um a very eloquent Layman's
description of the body of work yeah
that uh led to the prize could you
reprise that again for our audience uh I
can try yeah I can try um yeah so the
the uh the particular piece of work I
mean we all all scientists uh have a
broader broad range of things that they
done but I think the particular aspect
of our work that was uh that the Nobel
committee focused on uh has to do with
cellto cell communication in the body
and it and it really relates to uh how
cells organize themselves within each
cell and how the cells are organized uh
and maintain a sort of synchrony of
behavior and uh in in in in in in life
okay so that sounds very general in a
new way it is but to try to make it a
little bit more particular uh uh for
example all the cells in our liver just
to pick a part of the body uh each one
has to you know metabolize glucose
properly otherwise you have diabetes but
they also have to communicate with each
other so that they all behave in a
similar way now those cells behave
differently than the cells in your skin
or in the the many types of cells in
your brain and so in order to maintain
the communication between the cells in a
in in an organ or between the organs in
a body so that the entire body functions
as a you know as we note ourselves to
function as an intact entity um there
are molecules that are released by cells
that that actually provide for the
language and a cell a liver cell will
secrete molecules that go into the blood
and affect the behavior of other cells
in the body even and and and and and uh
and even within the cell uh there's a
high degree of organization of the
processes in the cell we call it
compartmental organization in the field
of Cell Biology and these various
compartments also need to communicate
with each other and this is all done by
a process of uh underlying all of this
is a process called vesicle trafficking
which is what the Nobel Prize
recognized and uh and really what it is
is that inside um each of our cells
there are many tens of thousands of
little uh vesicles they're like cells
within the cell they're very very tiny
uh and they're they have the shape of
bubbles they're little spherical sort of
bubble like particles in each bub Buble
sequesters within it a packet of of of
uh of uh of of of proteins and other
molecules and depending on the nature of
the bubble the bubble can release its
content to the outside of the cell so
that that content gets released and then
a signals cells that are nearby or maybe
the content in other cases gets into the
blood and signals to an organ at a great
distance or maybe sometimes the the the
uh the bubble or the vesicle uh is it
rather than targeting to be released
from the cell targets some part within
the cell and therefore delivers its
cargo there and passes a signal in that
respect so in that there's an underlying
framework of what's called membrane
Fusion that's the technical term for how
a vesicle or a bubble merges with its
Target to deliver the cargo and it gets
very technical and Arcane but under but
the beauty of it is that there's an
underlying very sort of
simple uh biophysical principle that
accounts for this enormous diversity of
physiology uh that allows us to function
as an as an integrated whole and when
you have imbalances in these various
processes you get uh diseases uh you
know like type 2
diabetes uh there are imbalances in
neurotransmitters in most uh common
psychiatric disorders probably
neurodegenerative disorders uh and
there's a long list of of unfortunately
very common diseases in which these
pathways are are altered so I think the
combination of the sort of uh the very
basic principle that's involved and the
kind of generality is what uh in the
impact on understanding human disease is
probably what the Nobel committee was
trying to recognize in our work and that
of my colleagues Randy sheckman and
Thomas
Suda I recall uh from October that uh
you were asked you know was there a
Eureka moment uh for you a single one I
imagine perhaps there were many but if I
remember correctly you said well that's
not really how science Works um talk to
us a little bit about U the nature of
scientific discovery H um you know I I'd
say not a bad analogy would be playing
baseball okay so uh you know if you're
even if you're an above average hitter
uh you got to go to bat a lot okay and
so if you so you you know you have to
you have to be swinging and so you have
to pay attention and so you have to do
that but there's another thing that you
don't normally think about uh with
baseball which is that imagine the
batter isn't inside the stadium he can
swing all day uh and uh and nothing will
happen right so you got to be actually
you got to be in the right place meaning
in the stadium you got to be trying
pretty hard okay now now so the you know
Thomas Edison uh used to say that uh you
know inventorship is 99% perspiration 1%
inspiration it's very famous kind of uh
one of one of his more famous quotes
and uh that's probably true to some
extent for for scientific discovery so
the the perspiration is swinging away
every day in the lab in the baseball in
the baseball field in the stadium but
then how do you know that you're in the
stadium okay how do you know that you're
in that place okay that's actually takes
a lot of judgment and skill
intuition and uh it's not 100% clear
what that comes where that comes from
but that that's the piece that uh uh can
come in a Eureka moment oh you know I
really should be doing more this than
that maybe I should be looking at this
rather than that it may take a year may
take 10 or 20 years to exercise that
thought and you probably have to go to
bed a lot of times you'll make a few
mistakes you're certainly going to be
going to going to be thrown out quite a
bit okay usually you get to walk instead
of getting a home run but uh but if you
keep at it long enough and would
probably distinguish as the the best
scientists from uh those who uh are not
as uh fortunate or perhaps don't have as
much skill is the ability to be more
often in the baseball parks when they're
swinging rather than swinging it uh you
know into the thin air so I was I was
going to ask this later in the
conversation but I think it's
appropriate now what was what was what
has been your strategy for picking risks
because a decision right to focus on an
entire lab and the resources of that lab
uh for a year perhaps longer yeah um is
necessary but it's it's a risk how have
you approached that
historically yeah well Eric that's
really I these are really good questions
I think one of the the most fundamental
things is being willing to take a risk
okay now there most people actually even
scientists are not ultimately prepared
to take a risk okay and these days in
science maybe a subject we can touch on
again later uh it's uh it's actually
massively more difficult to take an
appropriate risk um there's a kind of
judgment that comes into it right so so
uh you have to feel uh well I'll tell
you when I was starting out okay sure uh
um uh I was really fortunate my first uh
uh job as a young Professor was uh uh at
Stanford University in the department of
biochemistry and the great figure uh at
the time at Stanford and indeed one of
the greatest biochemists uh of the last
century was a man named Arthur cornberg
okay so in fact I went to Stanford uh
because I was I was going to be able to
have my lab right
to do research teaching as a part of it
okay so uh and Arthur had uh received
the Nobel Prize in the late 1950s for
discovering uh how the chro how
chromosomes are copied in cell division
essentially uh an early version of that
and um at the time what he did was just
extremely remarkable the biochemistry he
did no one else thought would could have
imagined that it would have worked at
the time so I said Arthur how did you
decide just the question that you asked
me and he said well something like this
you know I thought I thought I'd try to
do something that nobody else thought
could be done you know uh but which I
thought could be done and that was
really worth the trouble now there's a
lot of that's an easy formula sure to
lay out it's not actually an easy
formula to carry out to carry out okay
uh and there's probably some luck in it
but you know if you're self-critical and
you wake up every day and you ask
yourself is this the most am I doing the
most important thing that I could do uh
and uh and is it is it really unique
enough then you will make discoveries
and that's the power of the scientific
method I'm going to take a question from
a viewer this one comes in uh by email
from Karen raso who asks what is the
most critical advice you give to your
students slost dos as they move into
their first independent
positions ah okay um well Karen um you
know that's um please go ahead oh I'm
sorry Karen that's a really interesting
question um you'll have to ask my
students in postto talks to find out if
I'm telling you the truth because
sometimes I don't always remember it
right but uh but you know my feeling is
that uh that uh that you um you need to
keep working in the lab yourself what I
what I and I tell this uh all the time
to uh maybe more importantly when uh
when we when we have a new assistant
professor at Yale and they come and ask
for my advice the way I did Arthur's
yeah I I went to Arthur cornberg what I
say is look you know um the best person
in your lab is
you and as a matter of fact you're the
only person in your lab so your best
asset is you work in the lab keep your
own F keep your focus on working in the
lab and even as your laboratory
grows uh make sure that you yourself
work with your own hands and I followed
that recipe for for the first 10 years
of my career and and a great many of the
experiments that uh that turned out to
be important uh I didn't do them all all
myself but some of them I did myself and
the ones that I didn't do myself uh
entirely I did some piece of so uh you
know there's a kind of intellectual uh
investment that you have through through
your own activity and so that that my
that's actually my single most important
piece of advice and the second one is
what what you Eric touched on which is
take a risk yeah and what I tell the
assistant professors are look you know
you're coming here and to a great place
Yale University other great places but
you have the resources now for a couple
of years to get started and to do
something
original and uh you know you should do
it and uh and if you take too
conservative approach you may succeed in
the sense that you survive in the sense
of Darwin's Finch but you know are did
you go into science to become Darwin's
Finch and to find a niche I certainly
hope not because if you did you know
please find another job okay let me take
another question this one uh by email
from Janet lions and uh this is uh also
a broad question uh she asks what what
areas offer the greatest opportunity for
basic research today uh and what what
areas offer the the greatest opportunity
for Tech transfer um and I imagine
different scientists would have
different responses but curious to hear
yours boy that's really tough
um if I you know this is I think um uh
that this might be another version of
the question what would you do if you
were starting out again okay and so it's
one that I'd like to uh address um the
first thing I would say uh is it lion uh
Janet yeah Janet sorry Janet uh the
first thing I would say Janet is uh is
don't ever listen to somebody like me
when you ask a question like that okay
and I mean that in absolute seriousness
because uh as an older scientist uh who
has uh matured and been well recognized
and so on I'm the least likely to
succeed if I were to start all over
again so my judgment is to be
immediately suspect nevertheless you ask
the question
so uh in basic science I think the
absolutely the most open area is the
brain um but not necessarily in the way
the brain is commonly approached uh the
common approaches to the brain more and
more Anatomy driven as they always have
been you know there's President Obama's
uh project to you know measure all the
connections in the brain and and and and
work out all the anatomy and so on uh
there is H sort of artificial
intelligence approaches to the brain
there are very cellular and molecular
approaches to the brain they're all very
good but I think they kind of uh missed
the point at some level of asking some
simple questions about the brain what
what what what I find amazing about the
brain is that all brains have
fundamentally the same anatomy of the
cortex they have six layers uh I tend to
think of the brain as a repeat structure
of cell with a common cellular wiring
and every portion of the cortex can be
used it appears to do any job it's just
a matter of what its input and output
are well that's easy to say what is the
underlying principle that explains that
circuit now there are people who are
trying to do that but there isn't in my
opinion anywhere near enough focus on
that question so whatever it is I think
the the understanding of what what what
allows mind to to emerge from matter is
the single biggest question of our time
I'm a little skeptical as to whether in
our lifetimes we'll understand it but
I'm not skeptical that in the long run
we will now technology transfer um which
maybe we should Define for viewers is
it's essentially the creation of
Technologies and companies uh that make
or those technologies that comes out of
University Research is that fair
description yeah that's a fair
description I'd like to redefine the
question though slightly uh the your the
first question clearly revolved around
basic science but let let me just say
let's say what could emerge from
engineering that uh because engineering
is a you typically engineering is the
use of scientific principles
for new purposes as distinct from the
discovery of new scientific principles
and Engineering is an extraordinarily
vital area and the area that I know much
much more about is biomedically related
engineering and I am
impressed uh by the uh by the potential
for the interface of machine and
body uh you know I think that we're
learning to as we learn more about the
brain for example in other parts of the
body as we develop more materials on the
Nano scale and we develop uh the ability
to uh manufacture on the Nan nanoscale
interfaces between body and uh and
inorganic matter uh we will uh begin to
see uh a merger of I don't mean to sound
like a science fiction guy because I
don't regard this is science fiction
we'll begin to see more of a kind of a
gradual coming together of machine and
man first in limited ways it's going to
take off first I believe in the
commercial Market with on body sensors
uh which will come out of uh Health
enthusiasts and the need for home health
and and healthc Care reform which is
going to drive stuff out of clinics and
more towards the home and and less uh
sophisticated interrogation by let's say
uh by uh experts rather than doctors
there's going to be I think a whole
series of events that are going to
provide the commercial driver that that
that that that essentially focuses
invention where there's a need and so I
think that's if you want to call it Tech
transfer you could call it that I don't
know if it's going to come out of the
University
or whether it'll come out of the startup
companies or some combination of the two
or maybe it won't even come from uh from
uh from the US I don't know where it's
going to come from but the world 50
years from now uh I think is going to be
uh really different in that regard
fascinating another question this one uh
via Facebook from Peter Cohen and this
is a slightly more technical question
but I'm sure you'll be able to handle it
do you think that a greater
understanding of path mapping in 4D
could be useful in the science
es um I'm not sure what we mean by I
don't know if we have a chance to feed
back to the questioners but um but if um
path mapping in 4D okay now I'm going to
interpret that hoping I get this right
sure I'm going to interpret that to mean
the fourth dimension is being time so
ordinarily when we talk about 4D in most
situations we mean three dimensions of
space and one of time so if that's the
case um I yeah I I mean I think we need
to understand certainly physiology you
know in the time domain uh and and and
another uh in my field uh you know speak
I've been speaking up until now about
most of the things I don't know about
which is something I'm asked to do more
and more these days and that's another
health warning but uh in the field of
Cell Biology and cell
physiology uh you know with we have new
Imaging tools that are really uh
astonishing now and the ability to
observe the uh biochemical and
physiological Pathways even within the
cell at unprecedented unprecedented
resolution
and uh and simultaneously in real time
is beginning to give us just the
beginnings of an understanding of how a
sell functions as a computer wow okay
because I know that people don't
normally think about it this way but but
something that you might think about is
uh that you know there in electronics
there's something called an analog
digital converter okay and it takes an
analog signal and it converts it into a
digital all or none outcome now we we I
think we understand that computers can
do that but most people don't appreciate
that cells also do that you know as do
organisms right so uh for example a cell
uh every every moment of its life is
making a decision do I continue as I am
or do I decide to divide and become two
that's an all or a decision you're
absolutely committed to divide when you
divide or perhaps you decide to move
around rather than stay where you are
okay and when that goes wrong you have a
metastasis and a cancer okay
physiologically though you need it for
healing a wound to bring in new cells
into a damaged area um maybe the cell is
damaged because it's for one or another
reason and it decides to commit suicide
as a kind of altruistic gesture for the
cells and the in the community uh around
it okay now all of these are binary
decisions but they're not made based on
somebody throwing a binary switch the
cell makes up its own mind autonomously
and the environment contains many
signals now you remember I talked to you
about signals that are released from the
cell for communication these are the
very signals that I'm talking about they
have to also be perceived by a cell and
and when you have when you're surrounded
by an analog Universe of chemicals you
can have a higher or lower concentration
of a signaling molecule or another one
that's an analog signal and yet that
that P that kind of H collage of signals
needs to be interpreted to come up with
an all or none outcome that's analog to
digital conversion that's a computation
that the cells are doing each cell does
it all the time we actually don't have
the foggiest idea how that works and
understanding what I believe the
questioner meant by 4D is probably very
important in doing that and by the way I
I'm guessing that that type of
computation is not so totally different
than what the brain does at a
multicellular level it's interesting to
think of a single cell as a
computer uh a couple questions back I
think we were discussing the question uh
and you said that there another way to
think about it was what might you have
done
in uh science um instead of what you
pursued if I'm not mistaken you uh as an
undergraduate started with math and
physics that's right and then uh found
your way to biology tell me about that a
little bit oh um yeah so uh I um I made
the mistake when I was at Yale as an
undergraduate as an undergraduate to
take a biology course and it just ruined
my whole life you know because I became
a biologist I'm kidding of course I was
I I had intended toh to be a theoretical
physicist when I came to Yale I can't
even remember not wanting to do that
which is kind of a strange thing when
you think about it for a kid uh and uh
and as a result of uh hearing just an
amazing lecture uh and my dad was a was
a physician and uh he insisted that uh
in a general way that you know I should
really at least have a look at at
biology at the time physicists weren't
well employed I don't think he ever
thought that I would really cut it as a
physicist he may well have been right by
the way and so uh so he suggested i'
take a take a course in biology and I
have to say I was completely resistant
to the idea because the first thing
you're taught as a physicist is that
physicists are really smart second thing
you're taught is that mathematicians are
even smarter okay third thing you're
taught actually is that chemists well
they're not really very smart but at
least they do worthwhile things and
they're respectable they may be dull
okay but biologists they are really
stupid so you know you are primed as a
physics student not to ever expose
yourself to biologists on the fear of
being contaminated but anyway I somehow
did and uh and that that was just a
turnaround and the reason was very
simple which is that uh that in physics
you know it's a very well-developed
subject and even if you're an advanced
student you're so far from the research
Frontier it's such a multi-layered
subject uh whereas in biology just there
are so many questions and as much as we
learn it seems like those qu there are
more questions and it's not not like in
physics you know with the string this
and the string that and the subatomic
this and that and you know I had a
chance speaking of meeting the other
lawat had a chance to talk to Mr higs of
the higs ban wow it's fantastic and I
still don't know what higs ban is except
it's obviously important to somebody
okay and I don't mean to make fun of it
but you know it's just even you know
intelligent people who really it's just
you can't get away from the math and so
uh but and and and and it is very
abstract and so but biology is in
molecular biology it's very
concrete uh you touched a little bit
earlier in the conversation um on the
question of uh how it was to be a young
scientist when you were starting out
yeah um I'd like to ask you um I mean
now you're teaching the future
scientists and working alongside them
how is it different being a young
professional academic scientist today
than it was earlier in your career
you know it's very sad actually it's
massively different massively different
when I was uh it's different in a lot of
different ways okay when when and I
started my lab uh uh in
1978 okay um in that era until you know
maybe 10 years ago I would say things
started changing about then in a in a
meaning meaningful way uh I felt free
okay I felt that I I felt free to study
something of fundamental significance
because it was fundamentally important
and ultimately it was recognized to be
so I've been working on that project
from the very beginning the the project
that led to the Nobel Prize um but um I
I I couldn't have Justified it other
than the fact that it was just something
that was fundamentally important it was
obviously important because it was true
for all of life but we didn't understand
it I felt free uh I didn't uh feel under
a lot of pressure uh I felt we pressured
self-generated pressure to learn more
quickly to discover as much as I could
um but I felt I had time uh to fully
develop a a a relatively profound
understanding of a subject free is the
main word today I think the the young
scientists that I know they feel
confined okay and I'm this I'm putting
it into a black or white box it's not
that simple yeah but even at the best
universities the the the the the young
scientists today are confined first of
all they're find
because they we we uh we give them
enough money we afford them enough
resources private philanthropy typically
to to have two or maybe even three years
to get a good start I had five years so
I felt free they feel
confined uh I started out with my first
research Grant at about the time that uh
that that you know I started out with
the grant when I started my lab
probability of getting a grant if I
wrote out an application for anyone not
just me was about 40 or 50% success we
talking about federal grants for example
Federal Grant from the NIH National
Institute of Health chances of getting a
grant if you wrote it out was about 40
50% and that was on the first attempt
okay uh these days the chances are about
10% okay sometimes less okay and you get
two chances at it so uh the new
assistant professors come without a
grant it's gotten so difficult that they
really are not even in a position to
obtain a grant for two years and by then
they're on the edge of running out of
money they're feeling confined they're
feeling press
and the result of that is it forces them
to uh to do work that's much more
incremental and less less involves less
risk much less risk okay the result of
that Society is that we are already much
less
competitive uh globally than we were and
uh this will continue unless unless the
the situation changes and uh and and and
how can it change uh I I had I sent
sense that question coming you know uh I
don't know that I have the only recipe
but the basic issue uh of course the
best thing would be to have as we've
always had in medical research more but
there's a limit to asking for more and
uh you know and uh I don't think it's
about asking for more I don't think we
should be going to Congress saying we
need to double the NIH budget it would
be nice by the way to have an increase
rather than a decrease that is true but
a modest single digigit sustainable
continuous level of support would be
very helpful but I think
that much of the problem that we're
experiencing today is of the scientific
community's own making it's not that I I
personally feel the government on the
whole over the last many decades has
been there for science in a in a strong
and a sustained way yes over the last
several years we've had issues that have
been disruptive like this the sequester
and yes uh the NIH budget has has uh has
been challenged and so on uh but I still
feel that uh that broadly speaking both
of our political parties are deeply
supportive of uh of sustained biomedical
research I feel that the larger issue is
how we allocate the funds within our own
family budget and uh and that hasn't
really been addressed in a serious way
now when you say the family budget are
you referring to within the within the
NIH the NIH budget has progressively
over the last decade gone more and more
been SP more and more of it is being
spent on top- down science projects
research projects more and more of it is
being spent on applied science so-called
translational research and therefore
since it's a fixed sum less and less on
fundamental research and it is probably
true in fact it's undoubtedly true that
10 years ago uh we were not spending
enough on translational research so that
the public and all of us being the
public get uh ultimately what we uh
should be getting from this basic
research okay but the pendulum may have
swung a little far uh to the point where
where where the uh you know the goose
that lays the golden egg isn't laying
anymore which is what I've been
describing and we we require fundamental
research and the other is that much of
the research is programmatic so in other
words in the past it was so-called
investigator research that was primarily
what was funded in other words uh a
young uh Jim Rothman or young Randy
sheckman starting their lab has an idea
and it's reviewed on the merits of the
scientific idea and it's not put through
a filter of what some big guy at the NIH
felt was an important program okay
remember my health warnings about you
shouldn't listen to older people when it
comes to uh that applies to the people
running the NIH too and you know it
depends on how you tally it no one knows
the exact numbers because the NIH
frankly isn't that transparent on the
numbers but uh I've seen numbers to
suggest that as much as half of the
research is essentially top down if you
include so-called uh uh investigator
initiated applications that are within
the rubric of special topics that the
NIH has requested that's a c change now
uh as you mentioned the the major
problem in your view isn't that there's
there's simply too little money and that
the government for example hasn't been
supportive but that they're allocating
it in ways that you might question I
there is too little money for the end
for the end user so to speak the person
to for the researcher okay there is too
little money for a research community of
the size that we have that is true got
it okay okay and part of the and and we
need to restructure in the broadest
possible way for having we've been
through an exponential phase broadly
speaking and we're now moving into a
steady state what the government's
responsibility is in my opinion is to
allow steady state growth in a
responsible way so that we don't have
yo-yos and bu budgets you can't have
projects that go you can't have
government funding that yoyos up and
down every 3 to 5 years and have 10 or
20 year projects which you need in any
of these areas of research including
translational research that's the one
but the other responsibilities fall on
the NIH itself itself to uh closely
scrutinize preferably with outside uh
outside uh analyst and outside views uh
how they allocate their money among the
different different bins to which it
could be allocated fundamental research
applied research top down for which
there's some value and bottom up just
good ideas springing up from Young and
Brilliant scientists and the third uh
party are universities like Yale because
as you get to a steady state we have to
change the funding formula to recognize
that we have to uh keep steady at the
wheel that's the government okay and
then we have to look at how we structure
ourselves as univers ities because we
actually have broadly speaking I'm not
referring to Yale but broadly speaking
probably too many participants in the
research process to be sustained by any
model of funding uh within the confines
that within the constraints of a flat of
a growing progressively growing but and
responsibly growing NIH budget and the
universities as a whole have not found
have not um have not responsibly
addressed this so you know we really are
challenged and it's not just fair to
point the finger at the government the
government hasn't done its bit for the
last couple years that's true and the
NIH I I don't believe has been uh truly
responsible in the way that it's it's
dealt with u dealt the hand of going
from exponential growth to to flat or
steady has not dealt with that as as
responsibly as it should but we as the
universities also have not been
Proactive or or sufficiently forthright
in my opinion is there a a role that uh
philanthropists can play and perhaps the
the private sector the cor you know
for-profit corporations in funding
science that uh that maybe they're doing
somewhat now but could be doing more of
and is that a good
idea well I mean of course there is a
major role Eric even now for
philanthropy in fact um the major
philanthropic organization in the United
States is the Howard Used Medical
Institution that is the major one
focused on biomedical research and uh I
shudder to think uh what Americans
America's competitive position in the
world would be today had there not been
the Howard Hughes Medical Institute over
the last 10 years now it's true that
only a minority of uh of of biomedical
research in the US is paid for by hhmi
is it's abbreviated but actually the uh
if not the majority certainly a very
substantial portion of the truly
impactful research is paid for by hhmi
an outsized proportion by probably in
order of magnitude and you have to ask
yourself why is that okay they have a
funding formula which is radically
different from the NIH with the NIH
funds are individual projects that are
reviewed on a forward-looking basis in
other words I say I have an idea and I
have here's how I'm going to go about
doing it and some folks on a committee
who never meet me personally or somebody
El I don't mean to personalize it sure
um will say oh I think that will work or
I don't think that will work or it's not
worth doing or whatever now the Howard
Hughes takes a different view they take
what you they look at what you've done
for the last five or 10 years and they
say did I like that was that impactful
and they don't look too carefully at
what you're going to do for the next
five or 10 years they look at what
you've actually done now people
criticize Howard Hughes they say yeah
but you're only investing in people who
have already
succeeded okay that's fine so maybe the
NIH and the Howard Hughes need to kind
of get their act together a little bit
and for the NIH needs to find a way to
invest in people who have succeeded but
invest in a different way as if they
were just not just out of the gate and
then Marshall their resources in a
particular way and they are trying to do
that for the younger investigators but
maybe more of that so there is a huge
role for philanthropy okay and it is
there today now having said that uh I I
think it's uh it's great for uh to have
philanthropy to help uh but but Phil
even philanthropy tends to be focused on
curing specific diseases and I think
that's very important and it will
continue to be very important but in the
main uh I don't see that as the solution
to maintaining our Competitive Edge in
technology in the broadest sense which
has always come and will always come
from basic science and basic
engineering on the day uh that you won
the Nobel I you were speaking to an
audience here at Yale and you related
little anote I guess you had met with
your research group earlier that morning
and you said guys it's not over
yet uh meaning don't slack off there's
more to do yeah what uh having uh having
done so much already what do you still
want to achieve in science you
personally well you know there's there
are questions that uh you know a
scientist in my position uh actually uh
you know put this Nobel rise aside
because to me that's it's sort of an
epip phenomenon on your question um it's
hard to to to develop a uh it's almost
inconceivable to imagine having an
impact in a major way uh in developing a
scientific uh Discovery uh in a short
period of time so I'm 63 years old I
don't know of I I I can think of very
few impactful pieces of work that take
less than 10 to 20 years so I don't
think I have the runway to do that all
over again as I did I'd like to think I
have the intellect but I don't think I
have the runway okay so what I'm
focusing on is uh trying to try to go
deeper in the questions that I've
Unearthed and so um you know we're
trying to understand uh we we've taken
the process of let's say vesicle Fusion
how the bubbles Target and release their
cargo for signaling and and other Pro
other biological events and we've now
learned how to not just we haven't just
in the past we discovered how it works
at a certain level now we want to
understand it at the level of atomic
detail so and and so that's a a process
that we're uh very much engaged in there
is a uh uh in the connection of uh of of
really finishing off a piece of work
there's one very major question that is
not yet understood appropriately uh that
relates to communication in the brain so
when when uh when in the brain you know
we have these neural networks of neurons
that have to talk to each other and one
guy fires an electrical signal and it
needs to transmit the electrical signal
to the next next neuron uh in order to
enable a neural computation to take
place that's ultimately what cognition
is about on a played out on a large
scale that's called synaptic
transmission and at the end of every
every nerve there are many little
bubbles called synaptic vesicles that
store the neurotransmitter same idea as
what I said before uh but a very
particular version of it and and when
the electrical impulse comes to the end
of the the wire the the nerve axone as
it's called Uh the neurotransmitter is
released and it passes the signal to the
next nerve to which that nerve is
wired now that the neurotransmitter has
to sit in these little vesicles waiting
for the electrical signal how does it
know exactly when to release it's not
how it gets released that's the general
problem how does it know when to release
if we didn't release our
neurotransmitters at the right time and
at the right place our brain would be
nothing but a confused fog okay okay so
timing is everything in the brain
absolutely everything and uh my
colleague uh Tom sudhof with whom this
award was shared well Tom discovered uh
the protein Machinery uh that controls
the timing there are two very special
proteins that he discovered but actually
we don't yet know how they work and a
precise way so a lot of what I'm doing
now is with other colleagues at Yale is
trying to be trying to understand uh
almost at an atomic level and we will
succeed over the next five or 10 years
to understand exactly how the precise
timing in the brain is achieved now my
belief is when we understand that we'll
also have the means to understand
another level uh of sophistication
ultimately of the cognitive process I
can't prove that today but I believe
that that's truth so I do think they are
probably important uh elements uh I've
also uh start I'm also starting a
laboratory uh at University College
London uh we have a program at Yale
called the Yale UCL collaborative okay
at UCL they call it by the way the UCL
Yale collaborative they're probably both
correct and uh this enables Yale
professors to spend some time
significant time uh in London uh at
University College London to take
advantage of what they have to
complement what we have and also vice
versa and so I I'll be working in the
Institute of Neurology at UCL which uh
is uh really the world leader in the
genetics of uh of human neurological
disas diseases and uh there my clinical
colleagues there are very much of the
persuasion that there are many uh common
and rare neurological syndromes uh that
are so-called uh they call them synaptic
disorders in which the very proteins
that we study are likely to be altered
in the basis of these diseases and we're
just really at the tip of an iceberg in
terms of understanding how uh what the
disease impact is in Psychiatry and in
neurology of the discovery iies that my
colleagues and I have made uh are and so
that's one another ambition I have is to
try to see that through and uh and that
is something I'll be doing in London
primarily so obviously you'll be
spending uh quite a bit more time there
yeah yeah I will be excellent Jim
Rothman this has been a real pleasure
thank you so much for uh spending some
time with us and uh sharing your
thoughts and we look forward to uh the
results of the work to come thank you
aric thanks very much to all of you for
watching at yell live please join us
again next time